Hubsan X4 H502E Desire 2-3-18
I realized that when I had hit my tight position, my hands weren't in a fist.
During this moment, I was worried that I didn't have enough snap in my kicking,
and I tried to be more mindful of my footwork, as I didn't want to stumble against my balance.
Hubsan X4 H502E Desire 2-3-18
I noticed how my back stance wasn't as prominent,
And I didn't push my knees out as enough.
This one here, for this timing, or this particular part of the poomsae,
it needed to be a little faster, so I tried to focus on my snapping motion.
I had to twist my wrists a little bit more, but I feel like I was a little too soft.
And during this part of the poomsae, I noticed my body was too close against the camera,
and I needed a little more space for me to proceed with the next movement.
I think I extended my arms a little too far out.
Here, I kind of stumbled against my balance because I went off the mats.
I think during this moment, I was curling my wrists too much,
and I need to punch a little to my stomach area.
Here, I thought my kicks were fine.
I think my timing was okay because when I landed,
my heel touched the ground the same time that I did my elbow strike.
Though I think my hands were a little loose near the end.
And then I felt relieved when I finally ended the poomsae here.
You know who you're being scored in?
Your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation of the site.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So from the number 4, you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern.
And then with that one, any mistakes that you make,
if it's a minor mistake, you get a minus of 0.1.
If it's a major mistake, you get minus 0.3.
So I'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two.
So with a minor mistake, it's a very, very small thing.
So say we're doing an outer block.
If it's not your shoulder height, maybe it's a little bit lower,
or maybe it's a tiny bit higher, that's a minor mistake.
So that's a minor mistake. So that's a minor mistake.
That's a 0.1.
A major mistake would be, you're supposed to do it out of block in the pattern,
but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead.
So that would be a major mistake.
So, with a minor mistake, let's say pattern 1 for example,
there's about 20 steps,
it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14-15 mistakes in the 20 patterns,
sorry, the 20 steps.
So, the reason for that one being, it needs to be absolutely perfect to not get a deduction of 0.1.
So, it's not uncommon to say there's 20 steps and you made, let's say, 15 mistakes.
So, what would that be?
So, we'll leave that there on this side,
and we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score at the end.
So, a major mistake, say you're supposed to turn to the left,
but you turn to the right, that would be a major mistake.
So, obviously, we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes.
So, after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side.
So, the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6.
This 6 is actually split up into 3 parts.
So, we have 1, 2, 3 here.
So, with this one, for a score of 2 is your power and speed,
your rhythm is also a score of 2,
and your expression of energy is also a score out of 2 as well.
So, we'll start off with the power and speed.
So, with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches,
anything that you do, you need to be nice and strong, and it has to be fast as well.
So, it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch,
but it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category.
So, the next part is your rhythm.
So, the rhythm, when you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern.
It's not just really fast all the way through.
It's not slow all the way through.
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well.
So, you do need to kind of work on your rhythm, and that's also a score out of 2.
The last bit is your expression of energy.
So, what is expression of energy?
So, that's basically how loud you shout, so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well.
So, let's say you're doing your loudest shout.
So, your pattern really well, it's really fast and it's strong.
Your rhythm is really great, but you're not shouting very loud.
Or you can kind of tell, the judges can kind of tell that you're not really confident.
You're a little bit nervous, so that's what we need to kind of improve on as well.
So, I'll just come around to this side.
So, with this one, for color belts and black belts, it's actually scored a little bit differently.
So, if you're a color belt, you'll actually, you'll average,
so we're 4C,
judges actually mark you from, it's actually from a 1.1. So this is your average. So say you did
all right, you did average compared to everyone else, your score for 1, 2 and 3, it'll start from
a 1.1. So if you're less than average in the judges' eyes, you might go down to, say for your
power and speed, you might get a 1 or even a 0.9. If you did really great, you might even get a 1.3
or a 1.4. So each individual category, you need to obviously get as high as you can. If you're a
black belt, generally depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3. So 1.3 would be
your average that you start from. So say your power and speed was above average, you might get
scored a 1 point, say, let's say 1.4 for now. Say your rhythm was only about
average, it wasn't amazing, it might be just a 1.3. But let's say you didn't shout very loud,
so your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to say, let's say a 1.0. So with this
one, we'll come over down to this side. So with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10. So
1.7, 1, 2, 3. So you added 3.7. And so you made 15 mistakes. So with this one, obviously, don't be
too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes. This is with the judges. We have three
judges usually at the panel. And each judge, obviously, is very subjective. So from their
point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes, or you may have made not a lot of
mistakes as well. So that's why we have the three judges, and we average it out as well.
Okay, so say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes. So if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5. So this would be your accuracy score. So with our
presentation like before, we're still going to do the same thing. We're still going to do the same
thing. We've got a 3.7 here. So we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring. So
you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good. So I'll just talk a little bit
more now about this number here. So if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above, and you
do your patterns, it's not uncommon. Generally, for a color belt, the average
is about a 4.0 to 5.0. So if you get a number between 4.0 and 5.0 out of 10 for your pattern,
that's actually generally considered pretty good. So anything above that, you can consider
yourself pretty good. If you're a black belt, the average would say, because we're talking here
about the higher presentation as an average, anything from 5.0 to, sorry, 5.0 to 6.0 is
actually considered pretty good. And anything over a 7 is actually considered almost world-class.
So if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back
because you did an amazing job. So we just went through our form-save scoring. So just remember,
accuracy is a 4.0, presentation is a 6.0. Accuracy is during your pattern, presentation is after,
and then we get two scores that we add up, and we get that number. So with this one, obviously,
say I was judge number one, I would give you a 6.2. There was another judge on the other
side, maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did, and maybe this one would be a
little bit lower, it might be a 5 point something. Another judge on the other side, they scored
a little bit higher. So we'd get the three numbers, and then we'd average that as well.
So you're hoping that you've learned something from this video, and I hope you enjoyed it.
I hope this helped you guys, so make sure you enjoy your form-save competition, and anytime
at any time.
Okay, we're going to practice reading. It's exactly, it's going to, so this is the minor,
and then major errors. And just, you cannot pause your video, but you can do it as a judge
to yourself. Yep, major and minor, and then after that, you can just click on power and
speed, coordination, and it automatically generates your score.
So if I were to, I did fall off a mat, but it was because I was too close to the wall.
Would that count as a major error then? No.
Okay. No, yeah.
Okay, so, we're here.
It's going to be the same as last time, except this time you're not going to be able to pause,
so it's going to be like you're a judge, watching your own performance. So when you press play,
or you press the space bar, it will just play through the whole duration. It's the exact
same video that you saw for your durations. Yeah, it'll be good whenever you're ready.
Okay.
All right.
So let's try this again, and you're going to look at your own performance, and then
we're going to play this time.
Oh, that's exciting!
So, let's say this is going to be a major error.
And the score is going to be a minor error.
Okay.
It's going to be a minor error.
Yeah, because I just saw you fall off, and you have to move down to your right hand
again.
But it was like I was sort of camping out, and I just fell off the wall.
And that's fine.
It's fine.
Well, that's not fair.
I want it to be a major error.
Okay.
Takk for at du så med.
Tack for at du så med.